the Minsk agreement was supposed to
bring a long lasting peace to Ukraine
but few of the articles contained in the
agreement have yet been realized villota
me Reuben belongs to a shrinking group
of Ukrainians who hope it will still
happen the former Soviet officer from
Kiev is part of the team who is
negotiating the release of Ukrainian
soldiers who have been surrounded by
pro-russian rebels we visit a soldier's
hostel at kiev's my town square no
kimyou minion politicians have to be
clear with the people in Ukraine so that
they understand their alternatives
either war or the implementation of the
Minsk agreement which will surely bring
a secure and quiet life Rubin is a
well-respected person he helped to build
the hostel so that the men on the front
of a few days breather in Kiev after two
years of war opinions are mixed a song a
big closet at sea what will the Minsk
agreement do for the people will Russia
honor it what good is it anyway it
doesn't help oak listening I don't
support it you can consume EU the
ceasefire in East Ukraine is being
broken more and more often Kiev should
have regained control of its border to
Russia a long time ago according to the
letter the Minsk agreement there should
have been elections in the rebel areas
supported by Moscow a long time ago
lookie boo boo what kind of elections
can take place in a region of war where
chaos rules and people are being killed
who should be elected there yes Ashley I
think the Minsk agreement is working
partially the most important point is
the ceasefire and it's being honored
more or less what's important is that
less Ukrainian soldiers are being killed
and that the populations in Donetsk and
Luhansk are suffering less but yes go
girls go of us yeah you don't worry we
should have begun with driving them out
and then began with the Minsk agreement
then we would have had peace merely for
coy
after two years of war Kiev is a city
had unease with itself